kennt ihr das von musik für diese
tonleiter la la la la la la la la la
okay das scheine ich raus kommt beim
neuen video und zwar ja wie solchen das
jetzt am besten anfangen also wir werden
ja alle so mitschreiben große web
facebook instagram skype sonnenschein
kennt ja jeder ist ja auch eigentlich
ziemlich cool so ich meine da die an
oster kann man einfach meinen und her
schreiben aber mit der zeit fällt ein
was eigentlich so richtig erst auch so
früher waren halt probleme so jahres
sollte man jetzt vielleicht den anderen
nicht unbedingt sagen heute gibt es auch
probleme ja das sollte man es vielleicht
nicht unbedingt schreiben da ich
persönlich jetzt ein jude bin habe ich
mir so glatt
suchst du dir auch mal so ein paar
sachen aus die wir machen die jetzt so
eine mädchen schreibt immer schlecht
ankommen also ruhig so meine erfahrungen
mit gesammelt habt das sollte man nicht
machen aber es ist auch nur meine
meinung aber eigentlich ist das auch
logisch ich will gar nicht angefangen
ein fachmann wenn es euch gefällt oder
wenn ihr mir zustimmen könnt ihr gerne
mal daumen nach oben lassen und können
auch gerne immerhin kommentar schreiben
wird mich freuen
aber jetzt wo also ich fange einfach mal
ganz normal mit ersten punkt an ist ja
auch logisch und zwar was man wirklich
vermeiden sollte generell erst mal so zu
schreiben sorry ich konnte die nicht
antworten mein akku war leer
gut ist wahrscheinlich jetzt die beste
ausrede wenn man nicht geantwortet hat
nur die sache ist halt folgende und zwar
also wenn ihr halt mit mädchen treibt
und wirklich so von beiden seiten aus
interesse besteht seit x oder halt auch
vom mädchen auf jeden fall interesse
besteht oder generell eigentlich um die
einfach nicht antwortete so plötzlich so
einfach für drei stunden nicht und dann
schreibt ja sorry mein akku war leer und
wenn das wirklich stimmt ist es ok man
kann schreiben zwar kommt es nicht so
cool aber man kann schreiben aber
schreibt das wirklich auf keinen fall
wenn jetzt nicht stimmt und ihr
währenddessen heitmann online watt weil
dann denkt sie sich warum antwortete es
nicht geht die ganze zeit auf euren
kontakt drauf und sieht des online
so sind wir glaube ich viele mädchen ich
meinen jungs dann auch so ich auch
manchmal aber mädchen halt auch gibt es
zu wenn es nicht um seiten kommentaren
stimmen schreibt augen kommentar ja das
kann man eigentlich auch direkt so auf
den zweiten punkt übertragen ich meine
so sei wirklich niemals niemals lange
online und antwort hier nicht das ist ja
eigentlich auch so das gleiche
also angenommen du bist die ganze zeit
wirklich durchgehend online und
antwortest er nicht vielleicht mit dem
hintergangen ja vielleicht weckt sich
dann so das interesse an mir oder so ich
glaube eigentlich nicht da habt ihr
direkt verpackt oder ich meine bei mir
als junger ist das auch schon zum teil
so aber ich glaube bei mädchen ist das
nochmal extremer ich bin jetzt kein
mädchen die kannst dich sagen also wenn
ihr wirklich die ganze zeit durchgehend
online seid durchgenommen
dann solltet ihr vielleicht auch den
leuten die ihr euch jetzt etwas bedeuten
antworten vor allem jetzt wenn es
mädchen sind so wirklich das formulieren
okay leute kommen wir zur nächsten sache
und das habe ich mal gemacht und das war
ein fehler und zu habe ich einer
geschrieben das war eigentlich gar nicht
so hat gemeint ich habe nur gesagt er
hat das profil was du vorher drin hat
ist das war besser oder schöner oder
geiler oder ihr wisst schon aufgrund
ihrer reaktion konnte ich dann für mich
halt erschließen dass das gar nicht gut
war also wenn ihr wirklich interesse
habt so dann sagt das niemals sagt immer
borg eines profilbild auch wenn es jetzt
nicht so hübsch ist wie vielleicht das
davor
schreibt einfach immer ja sieht super
aus weil ich glaube okay das kommt jetzt
auf das mädchen dann aber von vielen
mädchen so das web profil bild ist
wirklich so dass wirklich krass wichtig
ich meine wer denn dann so was dagegen
satz dann ist das so als würdest du was
gegen die beste freundin von der sagen
kann man das vergleichen war das jetzt
ein guter vielleicht okay leute kommen
wir zum nächsten punkt ich glaube dass
das schon fatalistisch punkt keine
ahnung hab ich noch bedenken was ich
weiß es nicht
auf jeden fall das sollte auch wirklich
nie kennt ihr das von musik für diese
tonleiter la la la la la la la la la
okay das schwein ich raus also das
sollte wirklich niemals machen und was
ich damit meine also wenn es jetzt nicht
gerade einfach nur eine männlicher
freund von mir sondern eine freundin
oder ihr mädchen was hier noch nicht so
lange kennt schreibt niemals bevor er
gerade schlafen geht einfach nur ich geh
schlafen das ist auch wirklich gar nicht
gut weil wenn ihr dann wirklich schlafen
geht und am nächsten tag aufsteht und
euch dann fragte wann ist denn mit der
dies voll anderswo zu mir braucht euch
gar nicht zu wundern das liegt einfach
daran dass ihr am tag davor
auch wenn es total blöd ist irgendwie
einfach nur geschrieben hab ich
geschlafen schreibt so was wie schlaf
gut und bis morgen mit einem smiley oder
einem kuss miley ist schon eine
steigerung aber schlaf gut und träumen
was schönes also das ist auch schon
wieder ein bisschen näher das kann man
die schreiben zu mädchen will klar kann
man das schreiben schreibt einfach so
was das auch immer besser glaube ich
könnte ja meinen kommentaren fragen was
euch so aufzunehmen
zudem ein feld wirklich ein bisschen
interessiert ja eigentlich schon also
schreiben sie noch einen kommentar
vielleicht gibt es dann mal noch ein
video
sonst würde ich sagen ein bisschen zu
viel meinen daumen ok alex kam da wenn
es euch gefällt es auf jeden fall mal
daumen nach oben da würd mich ebenfalls
schon freund mal gucken wie viel drin
sind ansonsten aber nicht vergessen am
nächsten ist ein globales ähnliches
alter komme runter als natural ins all
ist eingeredet ihr oben links zweiter
mit meinem netz video das war hier
snapshot habe ich so ein paar snacks
öffnet ist auch wirklich was passiert
also texas auf jeden fall macht wirklich
freuen
wir sehen uns am nächsten sonntag wieder
rein